let's look at the angular momentum of
two particles one sitting here and one
over there and they are circling each
other and we want to determine the
angular momentum of a point on the
ground right here underneath that's our
point s and here's the center so the
circle has a radius R and here we have a
height H and let's have the particles go
counterclockwise because then we can
define our K hat vector to go up and if
these particles are going this way then
Omega is also going to be going in the K
hat direction in the positive K hat
direction so we know that L equals R
cross P so we need to determine where as
R and what's going on with P so our
vector goes here from point s to our
first particle our s 1 and here's number
2 and we have our
as to sitting over here and P the
momentum of the particles well if these
guys are going in in the contact walk
wise direction then the momentum of
particle one is going to go into the
board following the direction of the
motion and here P two is going to come
out of the board if we consider this
equation here we can already graphically
determine what the answer is actually
going to be and so we we do R cross P so
R cross P which means ll1
LS 1 is going to point in this direction
LS 1 and alternatively LS 2 is going to
go this direction which means if we add
these two components and we do want the
total angular momentum of the system of
both particles so we have to add them
we'll get here our our L of the system
so in order to calculate that we need to
calculate first the LS 1 and then Els 2
and then we need to add them the crucial
point here is to be careful with the
coordinate system for the first particle
K is going up and R is going outward and
theta hat is going into the board then
we can write up L as 1 equals R 1 or s 1
Cross P 1 and we can express this vector
here with H and with r so we have R in
the R hat direction plus age
in the K hat direction cross P and P is
the the mass of the particle times the
angular velocity the component that is
our Omega Z and that goes in theta
direction so we need to solve this cross
product here and we're going to have R
squared Omega Z and then we have our hat
cross theta hat that K hat plus H R
Omega Z and then we have K hat cross
theta hat that's anti cyclic and we get
an R hat and this is by the way in R 1
and this is an R 1 and we get a minus
because it's anti cyclic so we're gonna
turn this here into a minus and that is
the momentum angular momentum for our
first particle now we're going to do the
same in an analogous way for our
particle number 2 but again we need to
look at the coordinate system that's
very crucial here so k head still goes
up our head now goes to the other into
the other direction and accordingly
theta hat comes out of the board and
then we can just write down our LS 2
here as thing M R squared Omega ZK hat
and here we have minus H M R Omega Z R 2
hat and we know from from our set up
here
that R 1 equals minus R 2 had our 1 hat
equals minus R 2 hat which means when we
now put it all together we want L equals
L as 1
Plus ls2 we can tally this up and from
this we will see that the R hat term
actually falls out and we are left with
two times the first term so we have two
M R squared Omega Z K hat and that's
exactly what we wanted we wanted an L
pointing in the K hat direction
that's exactly this here and what you
can also see is that the 2m here is the
mass the total mass of the system namely
two particles we could add another we
could do the same exercise again for
four points because we'll add two here
then we would get for M here so this is
the the mass of the system and if we
were to add many many more points all
along the rim here we get to a solid
ring which means that you have we know
the total mass of the ring that that we
could stick in here or we can integrate
along the rim and then get to the total
mass here and we'll always get to the
same kind of form